The practice of jus primae noctis (“right
of the first night”) is, in simplest terms,
the right of the local noble to deflower local
peasant brides on their wedding night before
their newlywed husbands.
Precedence for this practice supposedly goes
back for many thousands of years, with the
first reference of something like it going
all the way back to the Epic of Gilgamesh
from over four thousand years ago.
This practiced (apparently) reached its crescendo
during the Middle Ages in Europe, and today
is popularly depicted in Hollywood in such
films as Braveheart.
But did it really ever happen?
Numerous historians have studied the subject
and the result is that it turns out there
is no solid evidence of this practice happening
in reality at all.
Not a single well documented incident recorded,
nor a single victim’s name passed down.
It could be argued that women in these periods,
in general, would not be considered noteworthy,
especially peasant women, but with a practice
spanning (supposedly) thousands of years,
and the presumable rage it would induce in
the peasant populace, not to mention occasional
bastard offspring and perhaps a boatload of
secret weddings to avoid the issue, odds are
at least a few documented cases would manage
to make it down through posterity.
Or even just a record of the law in some court
case, as there are such records of numerous
other laws.
But any such evidence simply doesn’t exist
outside of fictional works or, for instance,
cases where people were trying to rally the
peasant class against their lords using the
supposedly former practice of jus primae noctis
to whip the mob up.
In fact, the very first mention of this in
the Epic of Gilgamesh, we see the hero Enkidu,
who was sent by the gods to stop Gilgamesh
after the people cried out to the gods for
aid, physically blocking a wedding place to
challenge Gilgamesh over this appalling abuse
of power.
In another early account (in the 5th century
BC), Heraclides Ponticus describes how the
king of the Island of Cephalonia instituted
this practice.
Once again, the commoners weren’t pleased
and one man went ahead and dressed himself
as a bride and subsequently murdered the king
when the monarch tried to exercise his lordly
right.
For his efforts, the cross-dressing man was
made the new king by the overjoyed masses.
There’s also the matter of disease to consider.
While these girls were all (supposedly) virgins
on their wedding day, that didn’t mean they
were free from diseases that frequently devastated
life through most of history.
And, let’s face it, these lords weren’t
just sleeping with these women, but many others
to boot.
If the lords were truly sleeping with many
or all of these women in their little fiefdoms,
beyond spreading diseases to every corner
of their lands, jus primae noctis would have
been a deadly law for a lord of a fiefdom
of any real size, assuming he chose to enforce
it.
So it should come as no surprise then, that
while it’s possible there exists a few rulers
in history who actually tried something like
this at some point, as mentioned, most historians
think the vast majority of accounts are pure
fiction or exaggeration.
For instance, Louis Veuillot writing in France
during the 19th century stated: “Nothing,
absolutely nothing, in the archives of Justice
authorizes us to say that our forefathers
ever made a crime into a law.
If we search the evidence and the literature
we find the same silence everywhere.
The Middle Ages had never heard of the droit
du seigneur [aka jus primae noctis].”
Other European scholars shared Veuillot’s
opinion.
Germany’s Karl Schmidt penned a thorough
treatise on jus primae noctis in 1881, and
came to the conclusion that is was “a learned
superstition.”
Over and over again historians from then to
now have tried to find hard evidence of this
occurring and come up empty, despite the numerous
accounts, sometimes explicitly fictional and
other times thought to be, throughout written
history in nearly every major culture.
For instance, famed philosopher Hector Boece
in the 16th century described this practice
perfectly during the reign of the Scottish
king Evenus III and claimed the practice went
on for centuries.
It turns out, though, no such king ever existed
and much of Boece’s accounts concerning
many of the legendary kings of Scotland are
thought to be pure fiction.
Similar fictional trends are seen elsewhere
concerning this supposed law.
Back to Europe and the middle ages, what is
true is that in many feudal societies, peasants
were required to get permission from their
lord to marry.
This requirement was called the culagium.
This often involved payment of a fee to be
granted such permission (some claim this law
replaced jus primae noctis, but while there
is hard evidence of culagium, not so much
with jus primae noctis, as mentioned).
Besides an extra source of revenue, another
purpose of the culagium was the nobles safeguarding
their investment by making sure they didn’t
lose their valuable serfs to a neighboring
lord for nothing.
In essence, jus primae noctis in some cases
functioned as a tax due when a serf’s daughter
married a man not on the lord’s estate.
By requiring the tax, it also made it easier
to track such movements in populace, as well
as perhaps deny it when prudent.
In addition, in some areas the Church also
demanded payment of a fee to get the couple
out of a three day waiting period before consummating
their union.
(One can only imagine how they tracked this.)
During that three day waiting period, the
betrothed were supposed to be deep in prayer
to prepare themselves fully for their physical
(and spiritual) union.
Of course, payoff your local clergy and you
could go forth with a clear conscience.
In the end, let’s face it, life was brutal
for peasants, and especially peasant women,
in this era.
When they weren’t being wiped out by some
pandemic, humiliation and subjugation were
just accepted facts of life for those born
into the lower social orders.
Jus primae noctis or not, female serfs were
at the mercy of their lords (and others),
who really didn’t need an excuse, a law,
or a wedding to rape or assault the serfs
inhabiting their land.
The peasant class didn’t appreciate this
(or many other such abuses) one bit, and so
it’s no surprise that they would rally around
a concept like jus primae noctis during various
uprisings and instances of political discourse.
In slightly more modern times, this was, for
instance, a favorite weapon against nobility
and clergy used by the great enlightenment
thinker Voltaire.
(Voltaire also, incidentally, made his fortune
by helping to rig the lottery.)
As J.Q.C.
Mackrell states in his book, Attack on Feudalism
in the 18th Century France, “the Philosophes
used the Droit [jus primae noctis] as a ploy
to exaggerate the specter of oppressed Serfs.
(For them) no charge was too absurd…”
It should be noted here that at this time
in France it was also said that lords used
to claim the right of droit de prélassement
(right of lounging), a right of a lord to
use one of his subject’s entrails, freshly
ripped from the body, to warm the noble’s
feet…
No charge too absurd indeed.
Despite most movie fans connecting the nickname
“Braveheart” with William Wallace because
of the award winning film with Mel Gibson
(1995), in real life the specific nickname
actually belonged to one of the semi-bad guys
depicted in the film- Robert the Bruce.
While Robert (then the Earl of Carrick) really
did switch sides several times during the
Wars of Scottish Independence, there is no
record of him betraying Wallace and the Battle
of Bannockburn wasn’t waged spontaneously
as it seemed in the movie.
He had been battling the English for nearly
a decade up to that point.
Robert ultimately became the King of Scots
from 1306 and held that title until his death
in 1329.